Wow so this is is that you um man talk
about getting what you asked for in last
episode yeah a little slow didn't go as
quick in this one like I I think I got
the majority of what happened it's
pretty trippy so person I was back I
guess they're finishing off the the
pickles that he left behind and when
they when Jake ate the last one they
tried to go to sleep see they dream
anything and I don't it's not a dream
they were going through right or was it
yes and no okay they quit that up so
Finn weights up ish and Jake is
reenacting serve all these memories that
he had from past episodes which I
thought was pretty clever yeah and so he
waits for him to get to the part where
he eats the pickle so he can follow him
to see what happened
and sure enough he reenacts everything
and as soon as the falls asleep the
pickle the pickle jar starts glowing
Finn jumps in and it's part of this very
bizarre strange enjoyably confusing plot
about bringing prismo back where one of
them if the Finn has to wake up Jake
from this like you know the world's
perfect bed essentially even has a warm
glass of milk and he's gonna be sort of
like the new L also called the old man
that man no no I mean like what portal
or well what purpose did that guy serve
again he was like the something for
Priya for him
well that was his normal body that's
just a normal body yeah oh okay well
that Jake was gonna be the new normal
yeah pretty much
I thought it was like something else
again the keymaster or something I don't
know so so Finn has to stop one of the
versions of Finn waking up Jake he does
so and that Finn kind of sadly I mean I
write a fellow generally bad for him
even though he's like you know
what sacrifice himself it's like and to
be fair he doesn't know if it's him or
not yeah if it's like that for Jeff
amber the other version so he goes meets
himself and that bin
turns into a sword his new sword I
suppose the Finn sword and then that
Jake the one that didn't wake up so it
becomes the new body for prismo man you
thought Inception was confusing uh but
it it was fun I think it sort of had it
have fun with what you can do with it
and sort of how confusing it is I think
it's sort of you know I don't think you
can meet because then you might explode
wait so you originally when you talk to
me you're talking to an empty room yes
but I see you now
now what you say now is that come out we
don't have to yeah you know says they
kind of knew when to cut that off and
just be like you know what guys just
just go with it just go with it you know
I like these sort of openly acknowledge
that um it was very dreamlike I loved
the LMS or black world they create I
love Jake see action to it okay that's
cool let's go and ya know it's a fun
it's I like because it's like it's sort
of a return to like the continuing story
but it's not too much it's not quite how
I put it is overload but it's just kind
of with one idea bringing prismo back
and giving finn a new sword absolutely
and i liked it yeah um completely forgot
was it last episode with the thorn in
the hand
no that was I think was this one you
know don't cut so when he wakes up he
looks a sees the thorn in a way you know
whatever when after eating the pickle or
whatever
yeah he's the thorn in the hand I'm glad
they brought that back up cuz that was
something that has kind of like gone to
the wayside yeah I forgot about it you
know I remember he had like a flower and
he had a you know the grass thing and
everything but I forgot there's a thorn
left yeah no what I really liked unlike
a lot of shows that do like time travel
if you will there was only two sets
that's it there wasn't like 30 different
sets of fins and Jake's running around
there was just the simple two sets and I
liked that they could have gone over the
top and had like you know 30 40
different sets running all over the
place and doing all this stuff but it
was nice it was just in a sense
streamlined down to just the two of them
yeah and it's it seemed to make sense
that's like you have to keep the circle
going sort of this you know if you don't
and I thought they demonstrated that
pretty well with Finn not interrupting
Jake in the beginning mm-hmm cuz at
first I was like I was thinking back
like well why did you really just show
them I think that helped demonstrate
more you can't disrupt the cycle you
know like if you do that then it's like
the cycle is exactly that broken and
everything crumbles
you know you CJ keep blowing up so I
guess it I guess it has since they
killed a bunch of Jake's maybe or what
that dream Jake any who knows and yeah I
like that too how there's just this
endless cycle and only one gets out that
like kind of breaks if you know in a
sense like you know the so one Finn is
destroyed and then I'm ever Jake has to
sleep and be the new body but yeah the
one that was running that cycle kind of
gets out so it's it's fun it's it's some
pretty pre detail for a kid show because
like like yeah I feel like Batman at me
it's serious only something done similar
ideas but yeah kinda like what you say
like this really sir took the idea of
the loop and breaking the loop and what
can happen with it and place it maybe
enjoyably confusing I think it's meant
to be like this is hard to follow but
that's part of the fun yeah like I get
annoyed and bothered with I haven't seen
inception and I mean I heard it's good
and I heard is bad and I've heard all
different things but I think South Park
said it best in their episode in Sheep
shin yeah where they said just because
you make things complicated overly
complicated doesn't make it more
enjoyable yeah and again I haven't seen
the movie but that's what they were
talking about but that's how you feel
about a lot of time travel episodes and
like infinite loop episodes have just
chosen it in general they try to go too
complicated and you stop having fun
this one was just a lot more done well
again I think because you have that 11
minutes to yeah you can definitely serve
like you know you do have to keep it so
tight so you only keep it to like the
important stuff yeah so yeah no I I like
how is done I think that is a very good
point that like I think with Adventure
Time I'm glad I don't see this too often
anymore I think we started to see it a
little bit of round cow that matrix II
Christopher Nolan II like you know sir a
period of time where it's like
everything was like like you said oh
it's complicated and kind of confusing
so it it must be good you know ya know
it's you still have to have an
attachment you still have to care you
still had to be invested in it and I
think even though a venture time does
have kind of like a you know a
complicated continuing story uh you like
the characters you can watch something
like this and just follow it enough but
the reason you're watching it is cuz of
episodes like you know like the last two
we saw yeah it goes fly or everything is
Jake where they can just be characters
as well yeah so yeah no I I thought
worked surprisingly well this is usually
an episode that would like infuriate me
because I'm trying to you know cuz I'd
be questioning in my hair but I'm like
no because they sort gave that you know
come on dude I'm in a hurry thing like
just don't don't worry about like they
serve give permission to the audience
don't think too hard about it
yeah which as we know nobody on the
Araneta everything's too hard about
anything so yeah no I enjoyed it it was
uh definitely fun to watch so I'm just
happy prismo is back yeah it's good you
can ask him when I and I haven't seen
these episodes like I'm watching first
time along with him but when the title
card came up asked him I was like oh my
god Princeville yeah and I just saw the
pickles because I didn't remember the
pickle thing they left the pickles they
just like you just saw the pickle oh my
god approval like yourself excited yeah
I'm a dork here so um yeah I haven't
done these I was just uh yeah I can't
forget we usually end unlike funny notes
or something like that I'm so used to
doing V Logs with Rob
like see you later and it's like I'll
try to remember like yeah what I'll
usually do just gauge Oh boom
the kill just get the cat as scared of
gay apparently the Catholic Chur like
you're prejudiced cat yeah hello
where do you think he gets it from oh
that's it you know it does match well
with our clansmen barbecues though to be
fair yeah yeah oh he's coming for that
he likes a Klansman barbecue right right
yeah bring you sheets so how do you and
Rob usually indoors
well the clansmen barbecue no your view
logs oh I'm just like take care later
like something like that
no what's he do he just goes okay yeah
if they do it again and